let's read this first story
we have this in the daily mail
louisville democratic candidate for
mayor
shot at an attempted assassination at
his office but escapes uninjured cops
probe whether politician was targeted
because he is jewish
now that's the gist of the story they
say that someone fight at the campaign
office this uh this officer craig i'm
sorry this candidate craig greenberg had
his clothing grazed by the bullet
fortunately everybody is safe and this
may not be anything other than a crazy
person because we don't know yet however
i believe there was a member of the city
council who said this was was an
assassination attempt so apparently
somebody has been taken into custody the
the investigation is ongoing
there's concerns here because
as things get more and more intense in
in in the culture war and uh with you
know conflict between trump with the
durham investigation with the january 6
committee people become less and less
trusting so some feel like maybe this is
just some mayor of a city in in the u.s
not even one of the biggest cities but a
big big city for sure it's a big city
and it's just a publicity stunt or you
know a false flag or some other
you know whatever but i don't i don't
know i don't i don't fall into those
i i genuinely think that you've got a
lot of people out there
a lot of people some of those people are
crazy and some of those people can be
driven to extreme acts because
they're unwell
so hopefully i'll just say this i hope
this is it i hope there's nothing more
to this but the reason i think this
story was important to lead with was um
as we get more and more news about the
political conflict escalation adam
kinzinger just came out last week and
said targeted assassinations are coming
if there's going to be a new civil war
and then
he said to wolf blitzer i think it was
blitzer on cnn that we would be naive
not to think a civil war was coming of
course it's a trope at this point tim
poole mentioning it because i've been
talking about for some time but i when i
see a story like this after kenzinger
says
targeted assassinations then a democrat
candidate gets shot shot at i'm kind of
like
was he right
yeah are we on the are on our way i mean
we should be able to all universally
condemn this right and say
this is you know it's a a a terrible act
and we're happy that no lives were lost
um but i do think you're smart to say
let's not jump into speculation too too
much because we don't know all the facts
um but yeah a terrible action uh glad
the person was caught right you said
that they had they had caught the person
a suspect was was was caught and that's
important right it looks like the cops
did their job so that's like this it
could be nothing you know it's let's
hope matching a description and for all
we know they're like oh there's some
right right the fact that it's a
mayoral race just leads me to believe it
could just be random and the fact that
they're just speculating saying it could
be because he's jewish i don't know yeah
i thought it could be mob related like
he owed somebody money there's so many
ifs see that seems like more of a reach
than
this
yeah i don't know a guy borrows money to
try and win a win a campaign and then
he's not paying up or he's you know here
you go
he gets he borrows money now that he's
in in the race and he has a change of
heart he says i can't go through with
this the people need me and they're like
if you back out on us we're coming for
you
see that but i agree that sounds crazy
like you know what's the scary thing is
a political assassination seems to to me
to be the most plausible outcome that
somebody is just like the democrats are
crazy and awful and something like that
it's really a testament to humanity how
we how like because you're right it's
not like that's hard it's like driving
you know every day we drive these 2 000
pound things past each other at a
hundred miles an hour and just
car after car well fifty miles in both
directions so it's like car
and we just trust we live in trust and
we don't we don't veer over and ram and
but you could that's the crazy thing is
people could it's easy to fail in
reality and easy to go haywire it's
challenging but but we do it so well we
stay on the on the level so well i don't
believe any of the the false flag stuff
you know a lot of people think well i'll
say this first assassination attempts
really really help candidates
it's kind of creepy and awful that yes
but it it rallies people you get a
victim narrative so i think for for that
reason people would suspect a politician
of trying to stage something like this
to generate press
but i just really don't think i mean
it is it is like winning the lottery 10
times in a row yeah to get the
circumstances where a politician is
going to be like okay after you shoot me
like nah this guy the bullet grazed his
clothing i don't think this guy wanted
it it's it's i don't i don't even like
entertaining the you know the idea but
there are people who
absolutely are curious about whether
they trust them or not but i'll add one
more thing
that's kind of how crazy it is
politically that people would assume a
politician would actually
stage something like that you know yeah
but let's not forget one of the most
famous
attempted assassinations of all time
which was the assassination attempt on
reagan was because the guy was genuinely
crazy and wanted to impress jody foster
right right and it's like well reagan
was just the target because that's who
jody foster would be impressed at i
don't know if she was um i don't think
she was ever asked as a follow-up like
hey did you did you get the guy's number
she probably maybe she was maybe she was
like hey cool give me a call
obviously that's not what happened
impressed but not the kind of question
you want to make
so i mean it could be something like
sadly there are a lot of crazy people in
the world i'm pretty sure jody foster
has been asked about that that was the
hinckley thing right yeah and i think
she was like 18 at the time also which
is even weird like she was no i think
she was like wasn't she like 12. she
even younger yeah like imagine this poor
kid
like you're you're like a i knew she was
very my point was that she's young yeah
and it's like gosh
it was like traumatizing for this person
she was born in 62. when was he shot two
eighty one believe she should have been
nineteen eighteen nineteen something
like that okay so you were right yeah
but still very young person
and uh so there are just crazy people in
the world but i'm glad the mayor is or
the mayor of canada the mayoral
candidate is okay she was 12 when she
was in taxi that that's what it was taxi
driver right yeah i guess he saw the
movie or something but
yeah i mean
do you think it has significance that
this took place in louisville because i
know there was a lot of unrest there in
the summer of 2020 because of brianna
taylor right yeah that was my first
thought i was like louisville that's
really interesting but i don't know i
did kind of think about that because i
was like what if this happened in a
different city like if this happened in
chicago i wouldn't even think right yeah
it would be a random shooting it's
another day oh it's really dark
overlapping oh gosh i know like as soon
as i started laughing i was in a
different city i would have been yeah
this might not be politically motivated
for the sake of definition what's the
difference between attempted murder and
attempted assassination like what's
where does it become no longer
considered murder
how important are you yeah exactly like
a public official or something it's kind
of crazy that it's that way like nobody
assassinates a plumber yeah i mean like
oh yeah exactly a competing plumber
company oh maybe yeah shout out to all
the plumbers but as soon as the plumber
announces like if actually it's really
weird isn't it if there was a guy he's a
plumber right and he's like look man i'm
just here to fix the pipes and then one
day he goes outside and he goes
we gotta change the pipes in these town
and i'm gonna do everything we can to
change these pipes and then someone
shoots them like i guess i guess what
makes an assassination as if it was in
direct opposition to your work in
changing something about the public yeah
that's the first definition i think it
is yeah and there's an assassination
like the murder of someone because of
their office yeah not just
because of their personhood but because
of their age yeah but but didn't john
lennon get assassinated
um yeah but they think that was
political because he was so
assassination of john lennon or do we
say the murder murder no that's good
maybe the beatles just defy all
definitions yeah and therefore yeah john
was like gandhi like he had that kind of
political power yeah he was very active
in anti-vietnam war stuff i mean he was
very influential so and his wife was an
amazing singer
that's the one person that should be
pulling their music from spot yeah she
should not be able to
shouldn't be anywhere i don't know
young's back on spotify yeah let me
admit he's not back on but a bunch of
his music is still on and will never
come off because he'd already signed the
rights over
for compilations and stuff to a bunch of
the hits interesting i didn't realize
that it's all one big joke
it's it's it just feels like it's all
fake but but i guess the scary thing is
politics is pop culture
you know so i've been talking about this
for a while we as you know as we're
looking to expand and do more other
kinds of content and books it really is
like everything's political eminem took
a knee at the super bowl and everyone's
saying it's political and some people
are like you don't even know why he took
a knee like he may just been bowing or
something but just by getting on his
knee and like and then like he what did
he did was hannah's face everyone's like
he took a knee for black lives matter or
something and like it was something
maybe he was nailing down in prayer you
know i mean he's a religious person i i
don't know what his reasons i think it
was funny that was the one white dude
that's true the one white guy in the
heels no one else does like that's why
it was for you yeah but maybe it wasn't
maybe it wasn't political the thing is
the fact that everybody assumed it is
you know politics is pop culture so i
wonder if when you see a story like this
about a democratic mayor
or democratic candidate
it only happened because this is what's
in the forefront of everyone's minds
if they were talking about
you know a movie or a band like john
lennon like maybe just crazy people are
seeing someone on the tv and they're
like he's beaming thoughts in my head
and so they go out and go after him and
if the crazy people don't hear about any
of these people they don't do it with
politics being so paramount to
everything now
more crazy people you know might see
this people see these people on tv and
then target them it could be completely
not political i was thinking as a
species i think we've lost our childlike
innocence now that we have the internet
and we're able to examine ourselves so
well we we're no longer this innocent
humanity that we were 100 years ago now
and we've lost wait wait wait wait wait
wait but we we've also seen a lot lost a
lot of losses gone to our childlike
curiosity which we need as a species we
need to retain that what do you think
people were like a couple hundred years
ago they just they just lived in this
ignorant allowance of like let daddy
lead the way and we'll support our guy
and now everyone's like active well not
everyone but people are like hyper aware
of what's going on everyone everyone my
age is an activist you know or activists
you know yeah people are hyperware bro
back back in the day people like
they lived and breathed their politics
because there was very few people they
did but they didn't they didn't see it
like we get to see it they weren't able
to like listen to the president it
wasn't right right right isn't that
crazy like 1700s you'd be like chilling
on your farm and a mail carrier would
come with a letter and the letter's like
the president said these things three
months ago and you're like well how
about that yeah like imagine getting a
letter and it's like joe biden announced
he's taxing you he said this three
months ago it's already been passed by
congress you owe us 10 bucks and you're
gonna be like wait what
nobody told me that yeah
and then you'd have to you'd be bound by
it yeah and i think i think expediency
is has what is what the internet has
changed and that's a whole that's a
podcast in and of itself right but what
has it done to society the the ability
to know things in the immediate and the
impatience people have for not knowing
something right now yeah i think that's
what's changed when you measure heat if
heat transfer happens really really
really fast it gets hotter and so if
information is downloading your brain
really really really fast that might be
creating some sort of interesting
friction that's that's that's a good way
to think about it it's like um
if you're if you're driving your car and
you're slamming the gas you know your
car can overheat you got to let up the
gas a little bit so it doesn't get too
hot if people are absorbing too much
information in terms of politics and
culture people start to overheat and
there's no cooling off period people
need to get time to chill but it's just
it's endless
and then people snap thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm and don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time